all right welcome back to part three oh
the we start off with the loading screen
the other shilling shared in mom his
name voicing steadily rising pace urging
him to do it am I really doing this the
young boy thought instruct his victim
with a rock and his rhymed
ah this is a nice new set of environment
that
I think I just heard a monster hello all
right
that steps I don't like that 16 with my
18 the unreflecting African son will has
continued to plague our expedition make
it impossible to dig on the Eagle ask
how professor Herbert managed to find
the location in these vast paintings
have nothing like remains a mystery to
me when I asked him about the tum again
to me he told me about the legend teen
he known the mother of all an
interesting story in its own right but I
can't help think more later that evening
we uncovered a passage beneath the dumb
leading to sand covered stone struck
refresh so we're confident able to find
the tomb we thought it and ordered the
other so clearly way later in the world
dark cold nice tomorrow I shall lead the
man into an ancient structure hoping the
real who can reach the burial chamber no
matter what the professor came in from
me or dig should yield something
interesting to get back to you suburb to
dominate the British Museum alright so
exploring in Africa apparently I don't
know sure sure that was my voice
or whoever was was not the guy I'm gonna
kill
we'll see I guess
uh-huh what the hell what are you doing
are you trying to accomplish I love her
you can't throw the stuff it's like
if I saw miles that come in there I
would be like you I have a share
all right let's go - come on
chairs put those there
alright let's go into the catalog or
should we continue here I think we're
gonna continue here actually
all right pretty creepy room
we are very beautiful picture and this
is when I was camping in the why do I
keep doing that it's not funny
I'm not a French guy
all right here that's a really creepy
corridor I'm not going there
whoa
that was not human happy to corner
camp and corner
I've actually noticed I thought it was
something when the first episode when I
played it I was so scared I was playing
in the middle of the night alone and
with headphones on and that's that's a
lot that makes a lot of difference when
you play that game I have to say maybe
it's just less scary now I don't know
piano can't play it
Oh
a key sir
should every I don't know whatever
all right
yes I could do that
huh
lack some sort like that map
Oh
no it's alright I can continue um I'm
not really
Maps so
don't look in there
right now I'm not supposed to look in
there if there were monsters inside
layer I would piss my Patty's disease
just fall now there's someone fixed it
really poorly okay so here are some maps
of the Africa I would assume
Boris Boris schewe is that
some notes
17th of May oh it is Daniel's Mary so it
is I know that Mary crumbles it is my
voice I feel the need to document my
tribulation for I fear that my memory
will fail me if I linger today I took
some men and ventured into the dark
ancient passage Harvard our torches burn
faintly in the murky air as his lone
made our way through on the gone the men
were suspicions fearfully our girl alia
felt strange language the meaning to me
I mustered my strength and yelled at
them to continue down the slopes on the
broken surface a crudely carved my
passage confused me I looked much older
than the fourth to that Sanju
instruction we'd expected the full
twisting path emerging a great-aunt
ain't chamber the walls in line with
statues all I had ever seen
despite the on earth one quality I felt
a strange familiarity more than might
which haunts me still at the foreigner
chamber great labs don't see love I know
whether they heard I give the order to
raise it and as I pushed through the
narrow space the heavy stones on the
drop on him inside I was trapped oh my
lord but luckily I made it out alive
obviously
I guess that's cool and AH the flower
book you think this with me
all right
nope much of the castle is old there
hasn't intended to for centuries when
the shadow arrives it won't take long
until things start falling apart
they're just blind time anyway let's do
what we can
there is much to be done about wars we
should reinforce weak structures the
ground will tremble and there's a risk
everything will cave in on us especially
downstairs here here and there let's get
the servants working on it
all right so apparently they knew the
shadow was coming for them and that's
what made these castles so
creepy I guess East Wing okay so this is
a map of the castle I would assume
huh
it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really help me
and I've been working in circles now
the noise has creeped me out so
much
to say that Oh God didn't I just come
from there
Oh God I'm trapped
I'm first
I didn't they're walking here yeah I
want and then I walked out here and then
I walked in here and nothing I've done
so apparently I'm missing something
I opened this guide stops their thing
already
but now
how do I
continue
refused
some puzzle to this I would assume and
break the window
and parent probably need to collect
something
like my penis
that's my steer
that doesn't necessarily help me right
now
what about this
not breakable by and what about my penis
then work
come on what am I supposed to do
let's play the piano I might work
goddammit
haha what did I just do I broke
it in my hand that's pretty pretty weird
alright it's continued you have to be
Swift
when you activate the first one you hear
that if it stops you'll have to start
over is it all this a bit excessive how
that is gonna never be too careful
I knew it I knew it
all right so though uh-huh after we
Swift
let's be swift and find out of us
in an inner hahaha muscles all
isn't this all a bit excessive you can
never be too careful can you
I agree
so I partly I remember that and I got
the wine cellar QE apparently the
shutter than like that camp in the
corner
captain corner all right
very nice picture and that horse but I
made love to maybe two five times and I
called hello Johanna very beautiful very
nice very nice times indeed all right
let's continue our journey to the wine
cellar and I have no idea if the rocks
are gonna be there's got to be a water
another way out
yeah I knew it
I don't remember where I came from
though study
stem
that was that
making sense up I need that it
and that's the one thing the piano Ken
reminds me of won't budge goddammit
and oh
I'm out of oil
I have to say this game is a lot more
pleasant with that
uh-oh wait I have more
I just went if our weights here it is
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa why
some monster did you guys see that
I don't want let go there I'm gonna
in part I don't know which part do this
but I'm gonna in it